hey 42 here in 1998 in Houston a 41 year
old woman was abducted at gunpoint from
the parking lot of her apartment complex
the kidnappers took turns in raping her
a few days later the woman spotted two
men a similar age walking down the
street as she drove around her
neighborhood the men she suspected were
Josiah Sutton aged 16 and Gregory Adams
19 they were arrested but after intense
questioning it would seem as though the
victim had been mistaken the two men had
solid alibis which placed them elsewhere
at the time of the rape furthermore the
victim initially described the
assailants as short and skinny yet Adams
and Sutton were both tall well-built and
stocky the police requested blood and
saliva samples from both men so that
they could definitively rule them out
via DNA testing because DNA analysis is
infallible right the boys were within
their rights to say no but why would
they both knew they had no part in the
rape and were more than happy to clear
their names they agreed the samples were
sent to the Houston Police Crime Lab to
be compared against the DNA from a semen
sample retrieved from the scene of the
rape it was a match the results strongly
indicated that Josiah Sutton had been
the perpetrator of the rain but they
excluded Adams as a suspect
Josiah Sutton was sentenced to 25 years
in prison for a rape he did not commit
but how do we know he didn't well after
four years of incarceration
Sutton's mother who always believed his
pleas of innocence because of a small
fact that she was actually with him at
the time he supposedly committed the
rape was watching TV when a report aired
it was a peace dismantling the integrity
of the Houston Crime Laboratory that had
handled Sutton's DNA and that of over
500 other suspected criminals each year
it revealed how Houston crime lab
technicians and processes were woefully
inadequate and often wrongly interpreted
DNA test results Sutton's mother
contacted the reporters and they
arranged for her son's DNA to be
retested by another lab the results were
as clear as day
so since DNA did not match that taken
from the scene of the rape and there was
no way it could have ever been
misconstrued as a match unless there was
extreme negligence after spending four
years inside Sutton was exonerated and
regains the freedom that was stolen from
him due to the police relying on nothing
more than a single piece of DNA evidence
that was never cross verified for
validity and ultimately proved to be
wrong
Watson and Crick first discovered DNA in
the 50s but it wouldn't be until 1986
when dr. Jeffries used DNA for the first
time as evidence in a criminal
investigation before the widespread
adoption of DNA analysis the go chief
forensics tool was hair analysis lab
technicians would compare hairs found at
the crime scene we've not taken from a
suspect under an electron microscope
based on the color pattern and over
telling patterns within their hair
strands a conclusion could be reached on
whether or not the two strands matched
indicating the incriminating hair
belonged to the suspect in question
countless people around the world have
been incarcerated as a result of this
technique but hair analysis has been
superseded by DNA which is
unquestionably more accurate and
reliable hair analysis is actually still
used by law enforcement but usually as a
way to rapidly exclude potential
suspects without having to wait for DNA
results hair analysis is no longer
considered to be reliable evidence in
court in fact over the past 20 years it
has come to light as an over-reliance on
hair analysis up to the 90s resources in
the wrongful convictions of potentially
thousands of innocent people
a non-profit the Innocence Project was
established in 1992 to come to the aid
of such people and work on their behalf
to clear their names and set them free
often using more up-to-date forensic
techniques such as DNA analysis as of
2019 the Innocence Project has used DNA
to exonerate 189 people most of whom
were originally convicted based on her
analysis so don't get me wrong
DNA analysis is incredible it is by far
the most accurate and reliable form of
criminal evidence we have it's often
touted as being over 99.9% accurate it
is a scientific marvel that has helped
catch thousands of rapists murderers and
other criminals and prevented thousands
of innocent people from being wrongfully
convicted but like anything it's still
not perfect and a lot more often than
you may think
DNA gets it terribly wrong and I'm about
to tell you exactly how and why that can
happen almost always when DNA evidence
is incorrect it is not due to the DNA
analysis technology itself it is due to
human error first start the DNA evidence
can be collected incorrectly at the
crime scene crime scene investigators
are usually extremely well-trained to
mitigate any errors or causes for
confusion over crime scene samples and
by enlarge as they take the greatest
care and due diligence in their jobs
after all there was usually a person's
freedom at stake
yet mistakes do happen more often than
you might think at a typical crime scene
there are usually many opportunities to
take DNA samples from strands of hair
and blood splatters to saliva and semen
sweat samples can even be collected from
materials such as pieces of clothing or
bed sheets the issue is tough it's
extremely rare that any crimes
only contains DNA evidence from two
persons the victim and the perpetrator
an average room is not even close to
being completely sterile and they will
usually be objects containing DNA from
visitors to the house or there could be
external DNA upon objects that have been
brought into the home it's any point in
the recent past and this problem is many
times worse when a crime scene is
outside or in a public space imagine if
a murder takes place in an underground
tube station there will be DNA from
thousands of individuals and it is the
considerably difficult job of forensics
to find that single piece of DNA amongst
it all that is the most pertinent to
solving that case DNA is often forced
off as an emotionless entirely formulaic
form of evidence but the reality is
quite different there is much more human
emotion and decision-making involved
than is ideal there are actually many
points along the DNA evidence pipeline
where a human element is introduced
deciding which samples from the crime
scene are actually relevant to the case
is one such point which is almost
entirely based on human decision-making
rather than cold hard scientific fact
and unfortunately humans are infamously
indecisive and inconsistent to make
matters worse most of the time DNA
samples are mixed together if two or
more people have touched the same object
or worn the same item of clothing than
any DNA samples extracted will most
likely be a mix of those two persons
this means they have to be teased apart
later in the laboratory which is
difficult and prone to red herrings and
almost always at any crime scene
the criminals DNA whether it's from skin
cells sweat or blood is going to be
mixed with that of
victims the more violent and prolonged
the crime than the more likely that
mixed DNA samples are going to be an
issue and then there's the other issue
of partial DNA samples attempts to clean
up the crime scene by the perpetrator
afterwards or something as simple as him
washing his hands can cause him to leave
only partial DNA samples which can throw
the most experienced lab technicians off
the scent even causing mismatches with
the DNA against a complete stranger who
was never at the crime scene but may now
be wrongfully arrested when the DNA
samples do reach the lab yet another
human element is thrown into the mix to
dilute the reliability of what should be
in an ideal world a purely scientific
method I'm talking about basic human
bias the most commonly used forensic
method for comparing DNA samples is
called DNA profiling this allows a
hugely complex of DNA code to be boiled
down to a series of grafts on a single
sheet of paper think of each vertical
bump here as being a unique DNA signal
like a section of your fingerprint the
height of the bump signifies how strong
that piece of DNA was in the sample by
comparing two such graphs from two
distinct samples say one taken from a
strand of hair found at the crime scene
and the other from a strand of hair
belonging to the primary suspect the
forensic scientist can make a decision
on whether or not they think this is a
match and it is hence the same person at
first it seems like a relatively simple
task with little room for error but
that's only true when samples are
cleaned and complete which for various
reasons that we talked about only a
couple of minutes ago they almost never
are partial or weak samples of DNA
produce what's called noise on DNA
profiles noisy sections can
appear to be highly indeterminate and a
human decision must be made at this
point whether it is meaningless noise or
simply a weak DNA signal what's a signal
nevertheless this can be the difference
between a lab technician deciding that
two samples do in fact much or do not
match which can be the difference
between guilty and not guilty these
fringe scenarios often rely on nothing
more than the bias of the examiner and
this bias can often be intensified
because in most countries including the
US DNA samples are often labeled and so
the lab technician knows who it belongs
to
if they already suspected the jealous
ex-boyfriend of committing the murder
and the difference between a positive
DNA match and a negative is only a tiny
little piece of noise on the DNA profile
then the lab technician might opt to
declare it a match in his report whereas
if the samples were instead tested
blindly ie the technician did not know
the identity of the person from whom the
DNA was sourced then his decision may
have been more pragmatic and less
emotional and he thus may have instead
concluded that there was no match in
1993 in either Oberstein Germany a 63
year old woman was murdered in her home
forensics discovered mysterious DNA on a
cop in her home the DNA belonged to a
female but apart from that that police
had no idea whose it was then again in
2001 a 61 year old man was murdered in
Freiburg Germany the very same DNA was
found on a kitchen drawer
than what was recovered in 1993 the
police immediately suspected that they
could have a serial killer case on their
hands but since the DNA wasn't on the
police database all they could do was
wait until she struck again and
hopefully made and the
take the media branded the serial killer
the Phantom of Heilbronn others called
her the woman without a face over the
next eight years the police would
discover the Phantom woman's DNA at the
scene of 40 crimes all over Germany
Austria and France including murders and
burglaries but it didn't matter how
often the Phantom of Heilbronn struck or
how many times her DNA was recovered and
analyzed the police had no leads as to
her identity that was until 2019 when
there was a break it was discovered that
a female worker at a factory had
inadvertently contaminated several
batches of cotton swabs and these has
happened to be the same swabs that many
German French and Austrian forensics
teams used to collect DNA evidence at
crime scenes the mystery had finally
been solved there was no serial killer
all 40 crimes were completely related
the only link between them was the DNA
which was originating from the
contaminated cotton swabs the police
were able to confirm this because
Bavaria although being situated directly
in the center of all of these crimes had
no Phantom of Heilbronn DNA matches and
why was that because the Bavarian CSI
unit ordered their cotton swabs from a
different factory thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me on patreon which
really helps me to continue making these
videos also I've recently launched my
first book sticker flag in it a thousand
years of bizarre history from Britain
and beyond you can get your hands on a
first edition signed copy by clicking
the link in a description and heading
over to unbound publishing thank you